IN 2016.
BRETT?
>> LIVE ON THE NORTH LAWN,
THANK YOU.
SAYS PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD WAIT
ON THE SUPREME COURT PICK.
BIDEN WILL NOT HOWEVER SAY
WHETHER HE WOUOULD PUSH TO ADD T
THE NUMBER OF JUSTICES ON THE
SUPREME COURT IF HE BECOMES
PRESIDENT.
HE WAS CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
PETER DOOCY.
>> STAYED HOME IN DELAWARE TODAY
AS RUNNING MATE KAMALA HARRIS
HIT THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL IN FLINT,
MICHIGAN,.
>> SHOULD DEMOCRATS PACK THE
COURT?
>> THAT’S WHAT SOME DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS WANT TO DO.
FED STATES OF THE SUPREME COURT
I’M NOT
GOING TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
BECAUSE IT WILL SHIFT THE FOCUS.
THAT’S WHAT HE WANTS.
THAT NONANSWER SAYS A LOT TO SET
A MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH McCONNELL.
>> FORMER VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
HIMSELF REFUSED TO RULE OUT THAT
HE WOULD PACK THE SUPREME COURT
SUPREME COURT.
>> THAT WOULD REQUIRE A MAJOR
CHANGE TO SENATE TRADITION WHICH
DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN OPPOSES
TELLING REPORTERS I DON’T
BELIEVE IN DOING THAT.
I THINK THE FILIBUSTER SERVES A
PURPOSE WHEN I THINK IT’S PART
OF THE SENATE THAT
DIFFERENTIATES ITSELF.
TWO NEW POLLS REVEAL UNDER THE
RADAR BATTLEGROUNDS, GEORGE’S
LIKELY VOTERS BY 0.3% AND A
CONSTITUTION POLE AND THE LIKELY
VOTERS ARE SPLIT.
FEELS LIKE A LIFETIME SINCE
BERNIE SANDERS WON THE IOWA
CAUCUS POPULAR VOTE ESPECIALLY
SINCE SO MUCH OF BIDEN’S PITCHES
HE’S NOT BERNIE.
>> I BEAT THE SOCIALIST, THAT’S
HOW I GOT THE NOMINATION.
DO I LOOK LIKE A SOCIALIST?
>> ASKED THE VP NOMINEE A SECOND
TIME TODAY IN MICHIGAN.
>> SHOULD DEMOCRATS TRY TO PACK
THE COURT NEXT YEAR?
WE TRIED, AND WE WILL KEEP
ASKING ALTHOUGH IF THE LAST TWO
DAYS OF CAMPAIGN EVENTS SIGNAL
ANYTHING, IT’S THAT THE BIDEN
BRAIN TRUST BELIEVES OTHER
ISSUES ARE BIGGER WINNERS FOR
THEM THAN THE COMING
SUPREME COURT FIGHT AND
ESPECIALLY THE ECONOMY AND